MEMBERS AND FRIENDS OF THE
LGBT COMMUNITY.
MANY OF THEM LATINO.
>> Katie: LEAVE IT TO A
FAVORITE OUTLET OF THE LEFT TO
EXPOSE THE ASSERTIONS AS
UTTERLY FALSE.
A NEW REPORT BY THE HUFFINGTON
POST PROCLAIMS THAT EVERYONE
GOT THE PULSE MASSACRE STORY
WRONG.
DETAILS HOW THE TRIAL OF
MATEEN'S WIFE NOOR SALMAN
REVEALED THE ASSAULT OF THE
NIGHTCLUB WAS A CRIME OF
RANDOM STUDENT AND DRIVEN BY
ALLEGIANCE TO ISIS.
JOINING US FROM
COUNTERTERRORISM ANALYST.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> MY PLEASURE.
>> Katie: MY FIRST QUESTION
IS WHY IS IT WHEN WE HAVE SOME
SORT OF TERRORIST ATTACK LIKE
THIS, GOD FORBID ON AMERICAN
SOIL, OR OVERSEAS FRANKLY, THE
LEFT AND THE MEDIA OUGHT
MATTICLY GO TO FIND A MOTIVE
THAT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
THE ACTUAL SITUATION?
>> YEAH.
THAT IS THE QUESTION HERE
RIGHT NOW.
TO SAY WE HAD PLENTY OF
EVIDENCE TO KNOW THAT THIS MAN
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO ISIS.
HE SAID ON FACEBOOK AND AT
OTHER TIMES THAT HIS ACTIONS
WERE IN RETALIATION FOR THE
BOMBINGS IN SYRIA.
YET BECAUSE THIS WAS AT A GAY
NIGHTCLUB IT BECAME A HATE
CRIME.
THE QUESTION BECOMING WHY IS
THE MEDIA SO QUICK TO MUTE OR
TO ERASE THE JIHADI NARRATIVE?
IS IT BECAUSE WE WANT TO BE SO
POLITICALLY CORRECT AND NOT
MARGINALIZE, YOU KNOW, THE
LGBT COMMUNITY HERE?
OR IS IT BECAUSE WE TRULY
DON'T WANT OR WE WANT TO
IGNORE THE REAL THREAT HERE
WHICH IS THAT THERE ARE
AMERICANS WHO ARE BEING
RECRUITED FOR PLEDGING
ALLEGIANCE WHO ARE IN THE
UNITED STATES?